bonsoir pierre 7,1 merci d'être avec
nous on l'a entendu trois autres
départements restrictions renforcées
aujourd'hui en france quelle est la
situation chez vous à rennes c'est une
situation tendue depuis deux mois déjà
on n'est jamais vraiment des sans doute
la deuxième vague mais c'est pas si
terrible que dans d'autres parties de la
france donc on fait pas partie des
départements confiné pour l'instant tant
mieux pour vous on vous souhaite que ça
dure
comment vous gérez la situation dans vos
au plus tôt à les choses se passent
plutôt sereinement pour le moment on
essaye de rester serein mais je sais pas
si le mot est un peu fort quand même en
tout cas on a le temps d'anticiper et de
pouvoir avoir un deux jours d'avant sur
les capacités d'accueil des patients
donc on refuse personne on a de la place
si on arrive à accueillir tous les
patients qui ont besoin
comment vous expliquer cette situation
plutôt calme entre guillemets dans votre
région
il ya peut-être plus d'espacé gestes
barrières sont mieux respectés
on n'a pas d'explication très
convaincante on a la chance de pas voir
de grandes métropoles ça c'est sûr que
ça doit pouvoir nous aider pas de zones
de concentration de population très
importante
on a peut-être aussi une population qui
écoutent mieux les gestes barrières on
n'a aucune preuve pour dire ça a c'est
quelque chose qu'on aime bien dire et
puis on a aussi la chance de pas avoir
deux pays frontaliers
ce qui fait qu'on n'a pas été touché
comme par exemple italie a été très
touchée ça a certainement eu un impact
sur des les départements limitrophes
mais salle où on a pas puisque autour de
nous c'est la mer finalement bel et bien
de la chance en tout cas on va quitter
la bretagne 1 et vous demander votre
expertise de médecins sur le reste du
pays quand vous entendez voilà qu'il ya
des régions très tendue a notamment
l'ile-de-france et que la fermeture des
réseaux colle finalement reste un tout
dernier recours selon la sémantique du
porte parole du gouvernement qu'est ce
que vous en pensez vous vous dites qu'il
ya une forme d'irresponsabilité ou que
c'est plutôt une bonne chose
non non pas du tout quand on a eu la
premier les premiers confinement là on
n'avait pas beaucoup d'informations et
on avait la suspicion que les enfants
qui je vais vraiment
l'important dans la transmission de
l'épidémie ensuite on a eu des données
solides qui ont montré que leur rôle est
mineur dans la circulation du virus ils
sont assez peu contaminateur ils peuvent
l'être bien sûr mais beaucoup moins que
les adultes par exemple est ce qui fait
que le raisonnement entre le risque
qu'on prend à fermer des écoles sur la
santé des enfants y compris la santé
mentale et le bénéfice à la ferme et
fait vraiment plutôt penché comme comme
ait ça a été dit par le ministre je
pense que c'est le dernier recours il ya
sûrement d'autres choses qu'il faut
arrêter avant de fermer les écoles
peut-être les transports en commun
peut-être d'autres
d'autres pans de l'activité mais je
pense c'est vraiment bien d'avoir
protégé les écoles tank ou alors
pourtant les choses semblent avoir
changé
rien n'est jamais vraiment très clair
dans cette pandémie au début vous l'avez
rappelé on nous disait mon enfant ne
sont pas très contaminateur on semble
nous dire un petit peu le contraire
maintenant avec ces variants est-ce
toujours le cas que les enfants sont pas
des dangers pour les abus notamment
leurs familles et les enseignants
ce qu'on a vu sur les dernières semaines
c'est qu'effectivement l'âge moyen des
patients touchés à baisser un petit peu
mais il ya plusieurs phénomènes là
dedans il est possible que le variant
britannique est maintenant largement
dominant en france ne soit un peu plus
transmissibles chez des sujets jeunes et
puis on a aussi le fait d'avoir vraiment
bien protégé les sujets âgés là c'est
vrai qu'on commence à voir des
couverture vaccinale chez les plus de 75
ans qui ont beaucoup diminué le risque
dans ces populations
donc tout ça explique que les incidences
comme on voit bien là sur votre courbe a
plutôt tendance à augmenter chez des
enfants mais ça reste probablement pas
des grandes sources de contamination des
autres le plus souvent quant à l'enfant
quand il ya une épidémie dans une
famille ça vient de l'adulte plutôt que
de lancer aujourd'hui comment vous
expliquer cette baisse dans la moyenne
d'âge en termes de réanimation c'est la
vaccination qui qui explique cette bonne
et ça doit jouer un rôle parce qu'on a
vraiment beaucoup mieux vacciner on voit
que l'incidence a baissé chez les plus
de 65 ans les incidences de l'aco vite
donc je c'est sûr qu'on a réussi à
protéger les plus âgés en priorité comme
c'était prévu
mais il ya peut-être aussi l'impact de
ce variant britannique on connaît encore
pas très bien et qui a peut-être
tendance à pousser un peu plus les
sujets jeunes en réanimation sera
bientôt on
c'est une possibilité parce qu'il est
encore possible d'accéder à la
vaccination sans re confiné car il ya
malheureusement un beau décalage
je ne sais pas honnêtement il faut
surveiller de très près il faudra pas ça
ne fera rien s'interdire un finalement
mais on quand on voit les pays qu'ont pu
vacciner plus vite et de manière plus
massive on voit que à un moment la
vaccination fini par inverser des
courbes et on espère que ça va arriver
rapidement sans qu'on ait besoin de
confiner la france alors on a eu un de
vos collègues un professeur annan ce
matin qu'on a entendu que nous a pas
fait passer une bonne journée un pas de
retour à la normale avant la fin de la
décennie on nous dit il a quand on sait
qu'on est en 2021 sa pompe un petit peu
le le moral ce professeur qui la lient
laden qui ne voient pas de porte de
sortie
c'est pas un peu pessimiste tout de même
lire et animateur lui c'est quelqu'un
qui connaît beaucoup de choses donc on
va pas dire le contraire mais il y voit
ce qu'on voit de pire en ce moment
depuis quelques semaines un scellé
réanimation qui vont les moments les
plus difficiles donc ça doit forcer un
peu son pessimisme
ça dépend ce qu'on appelle le retour à
la normale mais non effectivement il y
aura pas de retour à la normale
probablement pas en 2021 par exemple
mais on va se rapprocher de la normale
et moi qui suis plus optimiste j'ai
tendance à penser que partir du moment
où on aura matinée plus de la moitié de
la population donc on peut penser que ça
arrivera un moment de l'été on va voir
quand même beaucoup moins de circulation
du virus et on pourra progressivement
levée des barrières sur les restaurants
sur les masques etc
merci pierre tattevin épidémiologistes
chef du service des maladies
infectieuses au chu de rennes d'avoir
été avec nous